in a face to nation interview secretary
of state anthony blinken says the white
house is working 24 7 to evacuate more
people from afghanistan
that country is close to economic
collapse after the u.s withdrew and the
taliban ousted the american-backed
government for a small number of
families trying to escape civilian
evacuation flights offer a lifeline mts
tae app takes us now inside one of those
flights leaving the capital
they consider themselves the lucky ones
afghans mostly families checking in for
an evacuation flight for a chance at a
new life
just getting to this point for so many
afghans has been
extraordinarily difficult and now
they have to take the next big step in
their journey
a journey into the unknown nabi roshan
is taking with his young family
one of afghanistan's most popular
comedians he hosted a nightly tv comedy
show where no one not even the taliban
was off limits but after it sees power
in august
russian says there's little left to
laugh about do the taliban like jokes
i don't think yeah i think so
did you receive any threats yeah
who
i don't know just said
i
i will
kill you
maybe
this evacuation flight is one of over a
dozen that have been organized with
meticulous precision by the government
of qatar the tiny persian gulf kingdom
has played an oversized role in helping
more than 70 000 people flee from
afghanistan since the u.s withdrawal
nearly two months ago
it's in stark contrast to the chaos that
followed immediately after the taliban
sees power and the desperate scenes of
afghans trying to flee
some losing their lives
in one of the many paradoxes of the new
afghanistan also boarding this flight to
the qatari capital doha are senior
members of the taliban government
including the interim foreign minister
amir khan mataki who stopped to speak
exclusively to cbs news in his first
interview with the u.s network
is the taliban prepared to have full
diplomatic relationship with the united
states
he says we want a positive relationship
with the world including the us but we
will not accept the military presence of
any country we only welcome diplomatic
and economic ties
there are so many afghans on this flight
who are leaving what is your message to
afghans who want to leave
if they want to leave they can leave he
says in our government all afghans
whether they agree or disagree with our
policies are free
but after just two months in power the
taliban has already stripped away basic
freedoms including barring most women
from going to work and forbidding girls
over the age of 12 from going to school
after 20 years of war the group it seems
hasn't changed very much
which is why so many of afghanistan's
best and brightest are leaving for cbs
mornings i'm impeached at the kabul
airport